[Music]  the pandemic has changed our world  we have learnt lessons  and changed how we deal with health  emergencies in the eu  to prepare better  monitor outbreaks  act quickly and make sure our responses  are coordinated  [Music]  we are working with scientists  businesses manufacturers health  authorities and others to detect new and  emerging health threats  develop and test the medicines and  vaccines we need to beat them and  produce more of those medicines and  vaccines in europe even at short notice  the european health emergency  preparedness and response authority will  help us prevent detect prepare respond  and recover  faster together  you